Oh Saiga  the place of beauty and darkness  do it south for the badlands arid  scorched only to war hungry orcs north  then asked the petty fiefdom zuv the  border princes and who black fire us  the mountains ones home to many Dwarfs  their numbers dwindle but some holds  remain strong  to the underwears the great roads below  now play like clean skins  lies the lands of NIMH and the Empire  each city are refuge bastions of light  flickering in the dark the least there  is only darkness for the dead and do not  rest easily in Sylvania  over the gray mountains very Konya an  easy ally or perhaps banana leaf and so  to the far north the ice crypt realm of  norske lies in the shadow of a twisted  power change is coming you must conquer  this world before others take it